[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the worst question i've ever heard
i asked how are you you know i actually
really like most receivers oh god are
you recording look i bought an actual
goddang lion
[Music]
all right what is up football nerds uh
it's me cartoon aaron rodgers
and i just want to say i'm sure there's
a lot of overreaction
after our week on loss to a guy who
hadn't played quarterback in over a year
and i just want to say my old
catchphrase the one
that you guys all used to really like it
when i said which is just relax
all right
uh
everyone stop me being me looking like a
sad cm punk and just relax all right
r-e-t-i-r-e
relax
all right
be like me and relax so much that people
are you know genuinely concerned that
you didn't train for your job as a
professional quarterback
uh so let's just relax
let's ask nice questions
let's uh be empathetic
and be zen like how i am and i you know
i'm perfectly happy where i'm at i want
to just get out of the way
this is everything is good everything is
nice
so let's ask the first question
hi aaron this is christopher
what is this
okay uh starting off a bad note
christopher what is this uh this is me
answering your questions you guys seem
to be like obsessed with me talking
about aaron rodgers drama any chance you
get that's what this is all right you
know uh
let's let's just calm down uh next
question we're here
yeah you uh you over there
hey aaron nba judge here why are you
fake
uh why are you fake nba judge uh i don't
even know what you mean do you mean like
why am i a cartoon are you trying to say
that i'm like a duplicitous person who
uh presents one thing to the media and
then acts a different way behind closed
doors all right because both both are
super rude uh you know all right next
question can we get like a real question
you guys supposed to be
journalists i know you're in the
bleacher report app but come on uh you
uh hey aaron this is bizarrock 13.
why are you 37 with a man bun okay uh
missouri uh 13. why am i 37 with a man
bun if you actually think about it uh 37
is kind of a natural age to be you know
sort of looking at your life and
thinking hey maybe i need to try
something different maybe i need to see
what it would look like if i you know
slick my hair back real tight and uh you
know gave myself a little bit of a
migraine and see if i actually think i
look cool uh so why am i 37 with a mind
bun um most people are who are with man
buns are in their late 30s early 40s
okay we're all just trying our best uh
all right
next question let's ask something nice
maybe uh all right uh you back going
down right here
hey aaron
elem here who is to blame for the loss
on sunday
all right i will answer this elam uh you
know ultimately
i take full responsibility i'm the
leader of the team
i'm i'm the quarterback i take full
responsibility now was it a little
ridiculous that we were playing in
florida and jacksonville even though we
were playing the new orleans saints and
they seem to just get to pick wherever
they want to play uh yeah that's uh
quite frankly uh irresponsible and uh
unacceptable but again i take full
responsibility i played i played like
garbage you know i didn't go out there
and play well
so uh
you know i just want to say uh the whole
florida thing kind of confusing you know
we play the packers in two weeks and uh
what are they just gonna decide or we
play the niners rather they just decide
that we're gonna play in like the mojave
desert you know i know that's ridiculous
so uh again i take full responsibility i
would never ever make an excuse but uh
yeah i blame florida next question
yeah you
hi aaron this is andrew code
she's curious is this actually live
yeah andrew this is actually live all
right that's why i you you submitted a
question and i'm answering it live
that's how this works
uh this is this is this is live all
right so anything i say is happening
currently somewhere in the world and
it's happening from gridiron heights
uh where i live with you know
hundreds and hundreds of other football
players next question aaron talk about
management aaron yeah i'll get to it
yeah you
hey erin e matthews24 here dude you got
benched for jordan love
yeah e matthews i did get bench for
jordan love all right uh look i know you
guys are asking questions in the app and
you have a lot of questions about you
know the way that sunday went but it's
one game uh but i just want to say uh
just get out of the way because i'm sure
you guys are looking for an angle
i was glad to see jordan get a chance to
play you know you know to watch him get
out there and you know not do better
than me i i mean i didn't love to see
that but i think it was important for
some people to see
um
you know that is just that is what
happened you know love got to play and
was uh you know just as bad if not worse
uh but me and jordan get along really
well you know but it's uh it's what the
great poets say you know if you love
something
you got to set it free you know set love
free is what they say you know get love
away you know actively push love out of
the organization uh you know get love
away so you can commit to a different
franchise quarterback uh you know you
know all the old axioms next question
yeah okay i will try to give you what
you need you
uh hey aaron this is uptown goat uh i
just wanted to say that jameis better
uh
yeah okay uh look uh uptown goat yeah
did james play better than me uh this
weekend yeah of course you did it'd be
tough for him not to uh trevor lawrence
played better than me uh zach wilson
for the on the jets played better than
me all right it was not a tough thing to
do
uh but uh ultimately you know i think
james is a hell of a competitor i think
uh jameis you know he also has three you
know three mvps oh wait no sorry sorry
sorry that's that's he does it uh i do
and i i won mvp last year uh but who's
counting was just one game uh next
question next
yeah yeah you
hey aaron the king 30 here are you
playing bad on purpose so green bay will
trade you
uh okay the king 30 uh i guess you know
the other 29 kings got there first
uh ultimately
uh no i'm not this rumor needs to be
rested uh did i play bad yeah did i did
i try to play well uh you know who's to
say
but ultimately uh green bay is gonna
have to trade me you know the other
season if i want to either way
let me i can guarantee that uh do i want
that to happen no uh obviously not we're
not talking about that we're not
focusing on that we're just focusing on
next week uh so know the king 30 i did
not play bad on purpose
uh i did not start to sabotage the ki
the team i've not grown to hate the
packers and this stupid uniform and
everything it stands for uh i played i
played i played uh you know my my with
my with my no not with my heart but you
know
i played next question
tell us secrets aaron yeah i know you
guys want gossip i'll try my hardest
what do you want
uh hey aaron this is orange blue true
you ready for that orange and blue
jersey
okay uh look i get what you're trying to
say i just want to say that um
you know i i love
you know green bay i can see myself
living here well no not forever that
would be ridiculous but you know i can
see myself living here for you know as
long as you know we keep immediately
winning super bowls and then immediately
leaving if we never don't
uh
so you know just does denver have a
proud tradition of you know doing really
well and and making making their
rebuilding their team around a a young
quarterback and then immediately tossing
that quarterback aside for a legendary
quarterback
kind of like myself yeah i guess they do
uh and uh does denver seem like a
a place that's much like green bay it's
cold but there's actually you know
things to do and culture and nightlife
and
you know big big houses that people
actually like are impressed with because
they're it's not just like that they're
big because they're in the middle of
nowhere but they're big because like you
know wow this guy clearly worked hard
and he lives by a mountain and it's
really beautiful yeah uh yeah i've seen
that about denver uh but uh really i'm
just focusing on um the detroit lions
next week next question
look i will try to give you all what you
need yes you
hey aaron ktm sports here could you come
save the giants from danny dimes
uh hey ktm look i i get it uh as i said
last time i'm not i'm not just you know
gonna say that i'm going to leave or
that i'm looking around shopping around
other teams uh you know did i notice
that washington and now in need of
quarterback of course you know
did i look at houses in the greater dmv
area you know you know yeah i might have
you know but that's just that's me as a
real estate guy uh so could i come save
the giants from from danny dimes look uh
you know you guys you have a quarterback
you have danny dimes and you have a gm
david gettleman and uh let's just say
that uh you know as long as he's there i
don't see myself there but yeah i guess
if the giants hypothetically this is
just you know a kind of uh
you know science fiction plot like out
of one of my fiance's you know divergent
movies you know if you know david
gettleman was to leave new york and uh
new york was to rebuild itself
completely around a you know franchise
quarterback such as myself you know i
you know i guess i you know come to
think of it i could probably film
jeopardy there you know new york's got a
good production you know set up you know
shailene would like that that'd be more
for her to do there uh you know kts
sports let's actually let's actually
talk soon uh we'll pin in this for now
uh because uh yeah i love the packers
sure next question
oh uh hey aaron this is next big thing
1998. uh you mentioned jeopardy why
aren't you hosting jeopardy
look uh next big thing
uh i'm an nfl quarterback that's who i
am all right i'm also uh i'm also a game
show host that is also who i am you know
you know and for a game show host i want
to stress i actually played really well
on sunday you know steve harvey would
have gotten destroyed by that same
second there uh but right now i'm
focused i got a lot of football left to
me and i'm i'm
i'm loving football this is so much fun
this is still my first love
uh and let's just say i think jeopardy
is like a scale or two away from
happening all right uh next question
i will try to give you that yes you
hey erin victor vasquez here messi
ronaldo
oh good question messier ronaldo
i like i like these questions i like
questions that are that not necessarily
about you know my intense details of my
personal life and uh my current inner
motivations so i guess i'd have to say
uh you know ronaldo is uh you know kind
of like a he's kind of like a pretty boy
ronaldo's kind of like the attractive
guy that everyone's really impressed
with that he's you know stayed so
attractive and has kept winning you know
uh throughout his career and everyone
thinks you know he looks so good-looking
and ronaldo is so great and ronaldo was
able to just go to tampa and immediately
win a ring you know but messi's but
people people forget that messi is uh
you know he's scruffy and and he's
actually really great and he's
unassuming and he's smart he plays smart
and he's just as good if not better than
ronaldo all right you know results
aren't necessarily everything you know
so ultimately i would say that you know
i'm kind of more of a messy guy than
that that that pretty boy with his you
know model wife or whatever ronaldo uh
next question
hey aaron this is tygo b
uh i was curious did you consult with
brett favre before the season started
uh interesting question tygo b
uh yeah let's just say uh
me and brett uh brett doesn't i guess
doesn't exactly love uh the old a-rod uh
you know after i kind of did what jordan
loves trying to do to me to him uh but
we did actually have one kind of fairly
interesting conversation we're basically
where i just asked him uh you know uh
was playing for the vikings that bad was
it as bad as it seems do you think i
could probably get away with that if uh
you know
if kirk kind of you know goes one way
this year and you know you know we set
things in confidence to each other as as
as quarterbacks and ultimately you know
he gave me some good advice which was
don't don't do not go to the jets no
matter what uh and i i did appreciate
that uh but really we just talked about
how much we love green bay and obviously
how we're packers forever and all that
all that garbage i think i got time for
one more question
yeah you
hi erin this is stink chili uh i was
curious if you thought miles teller
would have been a better choice for la
la land
oh good question stink chili
uh look uh miles is a close personal
friend of mine you know he's been all
the all these movies with my fiance
shailene woodley
and yeah on one hand uh you know ryan
ryan uh which one of those ryan's right
gosling you know was was fine in that
movie had a sort of natural charm but i
think that movie was really missing sort
of the whole
you know gruff uh
uh eagles fan who uh yells at you at the
at a bar thing that miles teller would
add to that movie you know miles is a
really great actor and uh you know i i
loved him and spectacular now and the
diversion movies and uh following our
stars with uh with my fiancee wait wait
what what is what is that was that that
was ansel elgort and fault of my stars
you're telling me shailene woodley
wasn't a you tell me that wasn't miles
teller uh look i gotta talk to shaylee
about that because
you could
those guys look the exact same to me
all right uh that is it for me
thank you all for your really really
dumb questions uh we're not playing the
lions till monday night so i'm just
gonna chill till saturday when i'll play
like one game of catch with randall cobb
and call it a practice uh later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you